[Aplausos]
eu vou começar a história o caminho
contrário a vamos mostrar primeiro
este remédio ideal urbanismo alberto
[Música]
sabe quem é e quem são outros grandes
atores e atrizes na realidade não sabe
mas vai saber
crystal skull coisas que os próprios
anel sábado o ju está só mais um
a defesa de ana rangel marsan é mau e
jornalista cantora linda johnson dizia
não saber quem é e quem são outros
grandes atores e atrizes na realidade
não sabe mas vai saber coisas que os
próprios não sabem bem que eu cheguei
aqui vamos recuar no tempo vamos para
1.988 sim eu 22 anos estava a trabalhar
em cinema estava a trabalhar num filme
onde estava a responsável tur vestidos a
todos a saúde no tratamento guarda roupa
e era responsável por respiro os atores
no local das filmagens e esse filme era
um chamado essa quiser ainda as chamas e
é um filme era uma uma composição com
vários países europeus e tinha um
orçamento absolutamente gigantesco no
japão lê mas era qualquer coisa como
gene a seu lado de seis milhões de euros
assim uma coisa nisso habitantes
tanto que significava que tudo o que de
melhor havia em portugal havia nesse
filme
até a primeira vez que tenha visto que
os tucanos não se sabem que estão sendo
que a marca acaba pendurada no corpo do
comandada por uma pessoa que era a
primeira vez que eu tinha visto isso
testei 88 fato havia tudo que era melhor
rio nas filmagens quando deve ser
responsável por tentar verificar se
estava tudo bem no guarda-roupa da
pessoa e talentosa e tal confrontavam
todos os dias com os eventuais problemas
que teve um espírito e havia um dia há
um dia que acontece um problema e que eu
fiquei a pensar que será isto qual era o
problema
o problema era muito simples era um ator
que era escolhido para contracenar com
um grande ator internacional e do
realizador dizia olha você tem que fazer
uma coisa muito simples
só tem que abrir a porta e servir o chá
e quando xata posto na mesa você só tem
que dizer lhe ter serve francesco totti
e o ator
o ator - a disputa depois eram
figurantes o ator já tava já percebeu
que teria que fazer
o ator estava sentado eu tenho que abrir
a porta e realizou se a ação se passava
na cota
lá eu realizo explicar a qual você
ovação tem que abrir a porta a porta e
diz o tse serve o aumento talvez aquele
que já percebi tudo isto vai vai
a ação da porta
o mal é muito fácil você abra a porta
põe o pé e do sltc serve exatamente
julho desta vez nesta altura estamos a
falar de público na época não era
digital como é hoje em dia se nós filmar
tudo não faz mal
a pepsi não custa imaginar vai então
vamos lá vai outra vez e finalmente a
terceira consegue abrir a porta porque
eu contar essa história porque o
realizador estava cansado o produtor
preocupado que estavam perdendo dinheiro
o ator profissional o conhecido famoso
cansado
perguntados quem as crises a que o homem
que não tinha talento para estar ali e o
dever de pensar assim isso significa que
alguém escolheu o ator certo voltar a
contracenar com aquilo tá tudo
perguntar o que investigar quem é que a
pessoa responsável por escolher caem
para o mundo que está lá os processos
todos e assim a tim é o caso em questão
é se a uma senhora uma pessoa um homem
na omissão ler se na maior parte dos
casos há mulheres que escolhem os atores
para contracenar uns com os outros e
talvez requisita
lá não é eu acho que é isso que eu quero
fazer avisa bom corta para apaixonar por
um assistente de realização e vamos para
paris vir porque ela era mãe francesa e
tá então chegamos à prisão e já naquela
do pai o cas têm até nós que é mesmo
isto cria fazer então comecei a pensar
assim eu caí
eu vou aquela biblioteca não via
internet né
a biblioteca do cinema francês e vou
procurar a palavra casca procura palavra
cacém e do com as entrevistas e normas
de uma mulher que era considerada é a
rainha do castelo chamava o mesmo
caminho do caso já tenha na altura vai
nos 80 anos e tenha começado no cinema
mudo meu nome é recorrente já pensei
assim aí tem que conhecer esta senhora
eu acompanho lata quer coisa que é mais
importante
eu acho que nesse tipo de coisa é ter
lata e então o lado da procura de saber
onde é que ela estava a filmar etapa
como filme que ela estava preparado é
filmado já preparado assim e pronto lá
encontrei um grupo forte não se aquilo
que falta produtores a se falar com o
amargo capaz de ela chamava se maluca
pele e passou o microfone e vamos
assinar assim como era um caso um mau
feitio wii e eu acho portuguesa
ele fala que o circo estava a fazer caça
irá a amanhã resgatar a bomba e não liga
muito forte eu reparo de tratarmos além
disso murada bom
não tive coragem de voltar a ligar três
da tarde sobre a morada na lapa e suas
três já está até a porta e press uma
senhora texto também um levantamento com
as demais todas curtas sem sapatos mas
deliciosa mesmo tempo sentia que ela
tenha se um bom ea assim português a
sentar se numa cadeira grafia
i de coronel luís miguel cintra
eu claro talvez miguel freitas e não
conheço miguel cintra aet koné maria
deve claro nessa linda e koné por ser
novo que até hoje é problema meu amigo é
assim não
a primeira regra do cacém pesquisa da
agenda boa sorte ao levantou se fossem
boca e ele fica ai pensei assim epa tem
que conhecer todos bom eu estou com
sorte que esteja a quilômetros é
importante isso vai acabar e não perder
o tempo bom
dito isto chega a portugal cheia vontade
de conhecer todos e sempre foi essa
coisa da eu tenho que conhecer todos os
atores no sentido em que eu não posso
lembrar depois do filme fight apple não
sei que você quer é bom papel papel 20
lembrado antes dessa coisa sotter
conhecer toda a gente por todas as
hipóteses em cima da mesa antes de
decidir quem é que é o papel ser o ator
certo papel certo é uma coisa que ficou
para sempre na minha vida não na minha
cabeça bom passou sem ter tanto para uns
16 anos depois e eu começo a perceber
que os atores vindos das escolas que via
as poucas a única que era o
conservatório nacional e vinham fazer
kasting cada vez que o espírita todos
buscassem são filmados na época o
trabalho sobretudo em televisão e cinema
cada vez que eles podia para a falar um
bocadinho mais baixas notas no teatro
não é preciso projetar a voz falando
carinho mais baixo 0 uma coisa não
querem confusão então dizia nesta um
bocadinho mas nunca nenhum palco é isso
ai daí segundo enquadramento enfim uma
série de técnicas que eu pensava assim
mas peraí
mas eu acho que não deve haver nenhuma
escola que lhes ensina estado enfrenta
uma câmera
eu acho que vou criar uma escola ensinar
foi mesmo assim e então comecei a pensar
bom eu vou fazer uma escola e vou
convidar os realizadores todos que estão
aí vou convidar os atores todos fazer
cinema e vou todos esses dar aulas e
assim foi
liga para vitor norte liga para nicolau
rayner professor também ter um pai
realizador de cinema e se teve que virar
a bola trabalhar não é pequena e até o
convence uma série de pessoas e cria aí
a actriz acto que hoje em dia vai fazer
dos secretários e é um projeto
maravilhoso que eu adoro me preenchem
alma todos os dias bom é uma associação
sem fins lucrativos não há dinheiro
aquelas coisas típicas que portugal é
sempre difícil uma pequena mas há que
fazer e fazer sem que schumi e é
maravilhoso ver que os miúdos todos e
cada vez mais amigos que quer ser ator é
muito difícil entrar na nato porque sou
entrão 20 por ano
candidato sustenta só é assim a vida é
vivida também infelizmente bom depois
chegou uma altura está aí há dez anos eu
pensei assim mas peraí eu estou sempre a
realização dos outros é sempre dos
outros é sempre a eu queria tanto ser
ator pimba tomar o papel
a eu queria tanto entrar num filme pimba
toma lá eu pensei então a escalar eu se
calhar nunca parei para pensar mas que
ela também tenha um sonho pessoal pra
mim fixa já está evidente com da imensa
roso realizar o sonho dos outros chegou
a altura de fazer o meu tocou com excel
meu a uma altura também que tem um
desafio de poder cantar num filme como
fazer daqui a pouco e recusa que roubar
e eu pensei bossa coisa que eu também
acho que deveria ir pra escola aprender
a escrever na escola há dois anos no clã
cantar fato começar a cantar aos 40 anos
não é nada mau
testou e quem sabe o que ela queria
dessas áreas ainda vou inventar outra
coisa qualquer bom nisto
cantar escola os carros a correr
lindamente não posso fechar o evento em
crise
paulo toma lá trabalha trabalho dos
filhos em casa difícil como é que eu vou
fazer meu deus
bom como tem tempo não tem trabalho e
tenho essa mania de guardar tudo vou
pensar num programa de televisão em
tempo o vovô que buscar as imagens do
passado porque sim
o diogo morgado foi meu aluno com 15
anos e joão bastos ricardo vaz tê la ou
não se camato falar assim dos mais
conhecidos e têm engordado essas imagens
de todas as desses caciques todos então
pensei 'eu nunca viram estas imagens
mesmo era eu compilar essas imagens
trazemos um estudo mostradas imagens e
fazemos uma conversa sobre como é que a
carreira de um ator
bom foi bater eu achava que sinceramente
achava que ia bater a primeira porta em
outro aí que exigem ao claro então não
sei que é bom
primeiro vai esperar um canal provisão
maps
ok não vou desistir do que acredito eu
não vou esquecer descobri que não
autorizam a não pode ser para não temos
grana não ser que não utilizar não
bairros da ideia genial desde audi em
almas não pode ser não temos netos é que
eu vou fazer agora
olha vou dar tempo ao universo a ser
universo dizer quando é que vai ser
agora não faço nada sabe que ainda
existe
sabe que isso vai acontecer não é já faz
as suas outras coisas fazendo outras
coisas está fazendo outras coisas do
tipo naquela a uma altura em que isto
vai voltar outra vez a carga
bom meu dito não a faz mudar a
administração da rtp e percebe é agora
agora vou lá
bata à porta tem esse programa
quer começar amanhã e pronto
o espetáculo vamos mostrar mais um
e consegui
violeta
luisa alexandra cultura e diana farrell
a cópia fiel é lindo e quem são os
grandes atores e atrizes na realidade
não sabe mas vai saber coisas que os
próprios não só dos seus 22 anos
bom vou acabar faltam 16 juntos 14 3 só
pra dizer é fibra livre e quem de letra
[Aplausos]
[Música]